hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in all things are possible lev shustaff
is going to talk about philosophy
at many different points which makes
good sense because he is himself
a philosopher but as a second generation
existentialist philosopher somebody who
sees the continuities
between the thought of what we can call
the first generation including
dostoyevsky and nietzsche who he writes
about very early
and then kierkegaard who he discovers
later and then other figures as well
he is going to have a particular
notion of what philosophy could be
capable of
and a critique and even rejection
of what philosophy typically is
and one good place to start with this
although you could read around within
his
his work is uh chapter 74
of part one where he says philosophy has
always loved to occupy
the position of a servant in the middle
ages she was the ankila
teologia which is the handmade of
theology as we often say
nowadays she waits on science in the
present age
a lot of philosophers subordinate
philosophy to science and then
wait for science to reveal truth to them
and then
at the same time and stressed off is
noting a little bit of inconsistency
or perhaps even hypocrisy here she calls
herself the science
of the sciences and
you might say okay well the the goal
then is to figure out what is the
relationship
between the disciplines and you notice
that it's philosophy
or sociology or psychology or other
disciplines
that's doing philosophy that typically
wants to figure out how do all these
connect with and subordinate and and
super ordinate with each other
and shustaff would would say listen this
is part of the problem
this is not really what we want to be
doing
you don't have to take your cues from
some other discipline you can engage in
philosophy by itself
philosophy doesn't have to tell
everybody else where they fit
and what they do which they don't really
listen to anyway they go on just
fine whether philosophy tells them that
this is their proper object or not
another example of this is in what he
comes right out and labels as
armchair philosophy in part 2
chapter 13. this is actually entitled
four
walls the walls of one's study and he
says armchair philosophy is being
condemned
rightly an armchair thinker is busy
deciding everything that's taking place
in the world
his chief business is to select his
statement so that there's no internal
contradiction
this will give an appearance of truth
and so that's what the task
really is there and he says this work
leads to very poor results why
verse similitudes of truth are not truth
what is a verse similitude
a an appearance of truth something that
has truthiness to use a term
that's made its way into the english
vocabulary in the last
10 or so years and he says that a person
who under
undertakes the talk of everything
probably knows nothing
an armchair philosopher sees nothing but
those four walls and yet of these
precisely they don't choose to speak
they don't realize their own contingent
situation they don't realize
the limitations on their understanding
of the world and of
all the possible experiences that
they're generalizing about
so that's something that we want to
avoid as well he also has a very funny
quip here in chapter 21 about
philosophy being in the hands of the
professors and as
if you read later on in part one you'll
see him actually
considering things coming out of popular
textbooks
at the time and saying look at this this
this stuff that's going on right and
he's not totally dismissing it but he is
revealing where it's pretense to
universality and finally getting at
everything that is important the
ultimate truths has
really been been ineffectual so in the
the chapter where he's talking about
logical thinking and that uh
it's real you know relation to
philosophy is certainly a contentious
one
he tells us it's difficult given
sedentary habits of life
to be a good philosopher you need to
actually go around and have experiences
in the world
he says the fact that the fate of
philosophy has ever laying in the hands
of professors
can only be explained by the reluctance
of the envious gods to give omniscience
to mortals while stay-at-home persons
are searching for truth
the apple will stay on the tree
and so you know what is he talking about
there
it's possible for a philosophy professor
to
have a wide range of experience and to
use resources arising in academic
philosophy to
go beyond just you know their four walls
but
it often doesn't happen and when you
think what
passes for philosophy in so many places
and how detached it is from
sort of the the you know i don't want to
say the history of philosophy because
chef stuff actually says
listen a big problem that we've got
right now is people aren't doing any
original work they're just
talking about the history of philosophy
but he does recommend studying history
for a very good reason he tells us that
if we
actually look at history we're going to
be
disabused of here we go to escape from
the grasp of contemporary ruling ideas
one should study history
the lives of other men in other lands
and other ages teach us to realize our
eternal laws
and infallible ideas are just abortions
take a step further imagine
mankind living any elsewhere than this
on this earth and all our terrestrial
eternalities
lose their charm by studying other
people and not just studying them so you
can figure out what pigeonhole to put
them in
you can come to some sense of the the
contingency and groundlessness of so
much of our
our thinking and our philosophizing so
um philosophy in the hands of philosoph
professors
uh not really philosophy in in a lot of
respects at all
it's what takes the space that should be
occupied by genuine philosophy
he also talks about the aiming for
spiritual serenity uh and this is in
uh part 1 chapter
103 says the summit of human existence
say the philosophers
obviously not all philosophers but
plenty of them is spiritual serenity
but in that case animals should be our
ideal in the matter of imp
perturbability they leave nothing to be
desired look at a grazing sheep or a cow
they don't worry about any of that sort
of thing the pasture is fine for them
and so if that's our goal then he thinks
we're missing something or we're missing
out on something
so what does he put forward as
if we want to call it an ideal if not a
universally binding one
of what the philosopher ought to be
doing so a great example
is what he calls not walking
the path of all gemaine gultekai here
he's making fun of the germans
uh he says the germans always try to get
at all gemaine guthike which means
validity uh universal
validity right gultek is validity and
olga mine
universal so something that would be
binding on everybody something that
would apply
in every single case and he says
if the problem of knowledge is to fathom
all the depths of actual life
then experience is uninteresting or at
least
has a limit of interest it's his net
it's necessary to
know what nobody yet knows and so he
says
we've got it's it's not robert frost two
paths diverging in a wood
rather it's like there's some paths of
olga mine goofy kite
and then it's not even going to be a
path necessarily it might just be where
the deer have run
and you're like i think there's a path
there let me go check this out you know
you you go off on your own or maybe
you've got a machete and you blaze a
trail
so he says um we must walk
not on the common road of all gemini
gulty kite but on new tracks
which have never yet seen human feet and
it could be that we don't have to pick
tracks that have never seen human feet
it could be that we pick
tracks that have been there
and the road was abandoned and people
allowed things to grow over it and you
can't quite tell but there actually is a
road there
but it's not a road of universal
validity it's a road
that somebody else traversed and we
could check it out we could try it out
we could say
i'm actually going to read cicero and
see if there's anything there
and everyone else is like why are you
reading that old book that's not what
we're doing these days right
that's not what philosophy is that's not
even for philosophy departments that's
for classics departments
you're like well i'm going to read it
anyway and so so much of this comes down
to our choice
to not simply go along the path
that everybody else is telling us to go
along that's valid for everybody
or that we want to be valid for
everybody
and the very first chapter of the very
first part
has this wonderful metaphor again using
a path or road or street
as an image he says the obscure streets
of life
do not offer the conveniences of the
central thoroughfares no electric light
no gas not even a kerosene lamp bracket
so they're not illuminated right
there are no pavements the traveler has
to fumble his way in the dark
if he needs a light he must wait for a
thunderbolt or else primitive wise knock
a spark out of a stone
in a glimpse we'll appear unfamiliar
outlines and then what he has taken in
he must try to remember no matter
whether the impression was right or
false
because he will not easily get another
light unless you ram his head against a
wall
and see sparks that way what can a
wretched pedestrian gather under such
circumstances
and he says how can we expect a clear
account from him whose curiosity led him
to grope his way among
the outskirts of life why should we try
to compare his records with those of the
travelers
through brilliant streets so much of
human experience has been homogenized
has been standardized is this all gemini
gutie kite
but where the real action is oftentimes
is off the
not just beaten but paved and well lit
track so that's a very important thing
to keep in mind
he also caution is it tells us to stop
treating
these old you know well-established
truths
with the respect that everyone expects
them to be given
he's got a great uh discussion here and
he says the best way of getting rid of
tedious played out truth to stop paying
them
this tribute treat them with a touch of
easy familiarity and derision
he says that dostoevsky did this and he
says
to do this will alone achieve you much
more than many brilliant arguments would
do
while you still contest a certain truth
you still believe in it
and this even the least penetrating
individual will perceive but if you
favor it with no serious
attention and only throw out a scornful
remark now and then the result is
different
you're no longer afraid of it you're no
longer respecting it and this sets
people
thinking he concludes so that's an
interesting tactic
he also suggests that instead of this
you know
universal validity this is a in
in chapter 40 towards the end of um
part two that we in fact he says
this is in a section called general
rules and he says people go to
philosophers for general principles
and philosophers get sucked into this
activity because they're human they're
kept busy supplying the market with
general principles
and he says now do we really need
general principles is that
really where the action is
is that what we ought to be supplying
and he says that what we ought to be
thinking about
instead of just simply trying to give
everybody
you know universally binding judgments
we should actually here we go there are
no all binding
universal judgments let us manage
let us manage our lives with non-binding
non-universal ones and he has got a
little
jibe there again about academic
philosophers only professors are going
to suffer for that
because that's how we actually do get by
in life we
we may in fact have things that we think
are universal and then there's always
exceptions the world is complicated
so that's an interesting one we start to
get into some
some more you might say skeptical or
cynical ideas
when we get to the point where he says
that philosophy must have
nothing in common with logic which seems
to be a rather extreme statement it
needs to be contextualized
by another statement where he says well
we don't want to throw logic out
altogether that would be
silly and extravagant but we certainly
don't want logic to be dictating to us
how we need to do things and he says
philosophy must have nothing in common
with logic y
philosophy is an art which aims at
breaking
the logical continuity of argument and
bringing the human being out on the
shoreless sea of imagination
the fantastic tides where everything is
possible and impossible
so philosophy shouldn't just be about
narrowing and restricting
our capacities it should be about
opening up our
imagination to possibilities not
necessarily saying well they're actual
because
we've imagined them that would be silly
that would be you know insanity right
but we have to acknowledge where things
are much more
open than we typically treat them as
he also has this really funny discussion
about deceiving ourselves
and letting everybody
deceive themself in their own way
now he thinks of the philosopher as in
some sense
deceiving himself he says philosophers
love to call their utterance
utterances truths since in that guys
they become
binding on us all right they have a
universal validity
but each philosopher invents his own
truths so these aren't really
universally binding
they're coming out of what their
philosophers preoccupied with they're
coming out of their context they're
coming out of their
existential station in life
and so he goes out and he says here's
what i'm going to suggest for you
instead of asking your pupils to deceive
themselves
in the way that they show and reserving
for yourself the option of deceiving
yourself
in your own way let everybody deceive
themselves just as they like
if you know that the reason why you're
attracted to say virtue ethics is
because there's something in you that
responds to that
you don't have to expect everybody else
to respond to that it doesn't have to be
a universally binding theory
that everybody covers and if you don't
fit into it you're
you know cast down among the swine or
whatever it is like that
live and let live you know
you don't necessarily have to think that
you've got your
finger on the pulse of the truth with a
capital t
in order to be able to get by in life
and do philosophy
finally uh he he also rejects he
recommends rejecting the services
of reason and and somebody who wants to
hold on to
chest off as being sort of a moderate
person in this
respect could um you know have some
troubles
with this he says that uh here we go
the only way to guard against positivism
is to not fear any absurdities whether
rational or metaphysically and
systematically to reject all the
services of reason
such behavior has been known in
philosophy and and he talks about
schopenhauer
and nietzsche as examples of this he
also talks about
credo quia which tertullian says and he
says this comes from the middle ages
and he says that you know these present
noble examples of indifference to logic
and common sense
and then he says i make bold to
recommend it so now in recommending it
is he recommending that we totally get
rid of logic and common sense no
no he's again going to be somewhat you
know
uh realistic about this but he is saying
don't allow those things to be binding
on you as a philosopher and don't impose
them simply on everybody else
and say you must do this or you can't be
studying or understanding philosophy
the last bit of advice that he provides
is one that he gives
not just to philosophers
but to writers in general and it's where
he talks about
logic and morality
and science as being police agents and
so i think this is actually
valuable for philosophers and it gives
you some idea what he wants to do
with with reasoning he says that the
task of a writer is to go forward and
share their impressions with the reader
this would apply
just as much to philosophers not to
provide you know universally binding
laws for everybody
and he says he's not obliged to prove
anything
but because every step of his progress
every movement
is dogged by those police agents
morality science logic and so forth
he needs to have ready some sort of
argument with which to frustrate them
you don't have to worry too much about
the quality of the argument don't worry
about being inwardly right
it's enough if the reasoning which comes
handiest will succeed in occupying those
guardians of the verbal highways
whose intention it is to obstruct his
passage so
you know you can you can say that you're
doing things in the traditional way
because that throws
these dogs a bone and keeps them
occupied then you can get on with your
real
job which is to philosophize within your
life
and make sense of things and be okay
with the fact that we probably are not
going to get the ultimate truths
but we can at least make our way towards
them and that you're going to have to
take
unknown paths from time to time and then
it might be a lonely process
you can do all that well morality logic
and science are over there
knowing on the stuff that you've thrown
them on the bone or the meat
of the rational argumentation and so
philosophy has a task for shestop
it's one that he doesn't say that
everybody has to follow he'd be
inconsistent if he
insisted that all of us must do
philosophy in chestop's own
way you know let everyone find their own
way
but if he happens to have brought us any
light
or help along the way we could certainly
make use of it
you